me
[音楽]
皆さん玉ねぎ丸かじりしたことあります
やっていますか
うん
甘え
私のベロメーターで糖度11度
まったく辛くなる
これはスマイルボールという新しい品種です私のところで後輩で作出しました
私は植物育種研究所岡本大作と申します
育種というのは品種改良ということです
植物を掛け合わせをして新しい品種を作ります
皆さんが何で玉ねぎかーと思ってかもしれません
ちなみに私が食べたこのタマネギのこの部分って
葉っぱだと思います武器だと思います猫だと思います
って上げてもらえますよ私を覚えてますから
パパだと思うと
ちょっとだけ武器だと思うと
結構多い猫だと思う人
ております答えいます葉っぱです皆さんほとんどを外れです
私も友達も言うんですよまたまでに研究して
スーパーに行ってもタマネギなんかいい種類しか売ってないじゃないかってねちょっと
悔しいですよねー
もともと音やサインなんていうものは世の中になかったんです
何千年も前に
道端に生えたり山に生えているようなものを人間が食べ始めてちょっと食べれるだっ
もうちょっと大きくしたいなねもうちょっと食べる部分を大きくしたいなーって言って
何千年にもわたって実は品種改良してきてたんです
で玉ねぎなんですけれどタマネギの原産地は中央アジアと言われています
今でも中央アジアに行くとネギの
メギというか雑草みたいなのがで岩場に生えてるんですって
私は行ったことないんです
おそらくそういうのを人間が食べ始めて
次は編エジプトにへ
ためやタマネギは行きました
これエジプトの音ピラー便土の中の癖が私美術館でねちょっと見つけてきました
唯一たんでねぇ
私の音知識ではねエジプトのローティラビッドの労働者に呻吟と一緒に玉ねぎを渡して
たっていう記述があるそうです
もしかして被害に玉ねぎが書いてあるんじゃないかと思って探しました
美術館でね横にいた学芸見たい人に聞いたんですよ
タマネギ持っているおっしゃいませんか
タマネギ知るかそんなの言われて私ずっとこれ壁画に出たんですよ
ついに見つけました玉ねぎ持っている人
エジプトに入った玉ネギは次ヨーロッパに行ってそして
メイフラワー号におそらく乗ってねアメリカの新大陸に行ってチン大陸から黒大に赴任
されたブループ先生がタマネギを日本に持ち込んだんですねこれが日本のタマネギの
最初の栽培と言われています
そんなあんまり
人気のない玉ねぎなんですけれど日本で一番食べられている
作られているや最低なんだと思いますか量で
お米とかねちょっと小麦とかお芋とかちょっと置いておいて生鮮野菜で一番たくさん
作られているためられている
野菜は
入ってください20位
タマネギって言いたいんですけどねサー位だそうです
うんまだ上に2つありますよ
キャベツいいですねキャベツに
もうちょっとうん1位ね大根だって
ちょっと意外ですよね世界ではん
世界はちゃんと統計がないんだけど一応言われているのは
雨でもでちょっといててくださいシャープになるものは
たまねぎねぎだそうですね結構いいでしょう
1位はに世界ではトマトだってでにが玉ねぎだそうですねだいぶ検討してますよね
そんな日まで気なんです
でタマネギの種の私は開発をしています
野菜ですからスタートはすべて金からです
タマネギのためてみたことありました
ないです私持ってきました
この中に入っています
この黒いゴマよりの小さいかなこの粒ひとつを巻くと今ちょうど種まきのシーズンなん
です私実は昨日までたで巻いてたんです1週間それを終わらせてきたんですこの粒米一
つ幕とあきみたまねぎっこになるんです
これはしますよ挙げてもらってもいいですっ持って帰らないでくださいね
これ1万円分くらいありますからね
だけどタマネギの中に誰真っ赤に入ってなかったもんね
じゃあタマネギのタネってどこにあるか
すべてのスタートはタネだっていましたけれど実はね玉ねぎは今種をまいて秋に玉ねぎ
になります
で私たちはその玉ねぎを食べて終わりだけど
私の仕事はその玉ねぎをもう一回翌年に植えるんです
そうするとどうなるか写真の通りネギ坊主って聞いたことありますねこれが実は
タマネギの花なんです
タマネギの一緒に年だったですね
で私たちはその1年目の人生しか知らなかった
ネ実は後半の人生があったタマネギの魂っていうのは実は自分の子孫を残すための栄養
タンクだったんですねこれを人間が食べて新たにいいとか美味しいって言ってたんだ
けどちょっと玉ねぎとっては迷惑な話ですね
これタマネギのネギ坊主にも種がちょっとつき始めているのわかります
ボコボコボコって
私の所では袋をかぶせてね後輩をしているところです
毎年700種類の玉ねぎを作ってます
私の友達がそんな種類がないよって言ったけど実は700種類の種を蒔いてきます
このようにした新しい品種改良してます
私ねもともとは努めています日本で一番大きな音
種の会社に勤めていましたどんな野菜でも同じなんですけれど品種大量の僕表というの
があります
どんな目標かたくさん取れること
ですよね
揃いがいいこととかね
日持ちがすることとか近いで収穫できることとか見た目がキレイなこととかね
もちろん安定供給という意味ではこういうことは重要ですけれど私たちが買い物にいっ
てねえ
揃いがいいこととかさそんな事を考えてないね球持ちがいいこととか
わたしそれで一生こういう目標で品種改良するのちょっと残念だなーと思って独立し
ました
でも大手と同じことをやったら絶対勝てないですよね
私何とか差別化の玉ねぎができないかと思いました
今までにないような球で日
でも玉ねぎはタマネギって言われたしな
ここで一つ重要なことがあります
タマネギの一緒にねんじゃないですかということは新しい品種を何台か作ろ
ねと思うとだいたい15年から20年かかるんです
今これができると思っていてもこれをやりたいと思っても今できないですのその時に次
15年先20年先に何が流行っているかみんなが何を求めているかを考えないと
で努力のベクトルが間違ってしまう
私ね2000年に60社と考えましたん
一つ厚木家傾向だろう
体にいい球ネリー
食べて美味しくて健康になる玉ねぎがあればそれは一つ差別化になるんじゃないかなと
思いました
その時また皆が言った言葉をれやすいため的に告った方がマシだ
今に見てろと思いますけどね
[音楽]
私ねそれでね世界中からねぇ
300種類の玉ねぎを集めて全部分析をして健康成分が入っているかどうか調べた
今まではタマネギはケルセチンというフラボノイドが入っててそれがメタボとかね
生活習慣病にいいですよということは知ってた他の野菜よりはそれが多いってことは
分かっていた
誰もだけどね同じ畑で300種類も作って分
てきた奴はいないのねそしたらねその成分が吉と遺伝をすることで品種によって
ものすごく高いものから全然入ってないものまであるということが分かった
これは多分育種できるぞと思ってね高いもの同士を交配して新しい玉ねぎを作りました
高いだけだったらまだ他にも顔料がね
成分が多いだけだったら他にもあるんだけれどやっぱり見た目もきれいで食べて
美味しくて沢山取れないといけないし病気に強くて農薬も減らさなきゃいけないし
いろんな事を考えてねこれもやっぱり10年くらいかかってさらさらレッドという
玉ねぎを作りました
えーと今ではね皆さん機能性とかって言うけどね多分私が姉
一番に使い始めたんですよ
機能性の野菜系高機能の高い野菜ってやつです
さらされると
もう一つ私考えました
私ちょっとかじりましたけれど
人類ね5000年間玉ねぎつずつ食べ続けてきて
タマネギが辛くなくてたらいいな
ね甘いフルーツみたいな玉ねぎができたらいいなって言ってた
よく言うよねあとた葉ねぎは口に入ると絡みだし
目に入ると涙が出ますで手につくとっ臭くなります利用の成分ですね
だけどそれがタマネギのことですこれをなくすことはできない
今までね実際絡みが少ない玉ねぎは
タマネギの成分を少なくしてたの
でもそれってちょっと残念ですよねタマネギの味が薄いなんていう
玉ねぎの辛味というのは暖流アミノ酸という
気質ですね元物質と酵素というのがタマネギの場所
中に別々に入ってて着ると酵素反応で
からに涙の物質ができるんです
玉ねぎを丸まま伸び米は絶対辛くないです
ありえないですよねうん
[音楽]
ん
みんなはその気質を少ないので玉ねぎを薄いのを得られたんだけどこれはちょっと違う
だろう
私たちは突然変異の答えを見つけてついにその酵素がない奴を見つけることができまし
た
そうすると玉ねぎの味がすごくしてね糖度が11度なのに全く辛くないという
スマイルボールが開発できました
見た目にも検討で美味しいタマネギさらさらレットと世界初ですよ
で涙のでない全く辛くないにスマイルボールっていうのを作ります
これまで農産物はなかなか差別化が難しい
俺玉ねぎ作りの名人だとかね真心込めて作ってますよ
それはもちろん言ってもいいんですよだけど科学的根拠を示して誰が見ても違うって
言わないとね差別化にはならない
だいたい農産物なんて需要と供給のバランスで買う人が値段決めてんですよ
そんなものやったって儲かるわけがないじゃないですか自分が作ったもの値段決めれ
ないんですの
自分が作ったものやっぱり値段を決めだけそのためには同じものを作っててはできない
ですよね
それで私は健康
それから
味ねこの2つでチャレンジをしてきました
ん
私独立してホント良かったと思います
自分の頭で考えて自分で動いて自分で責任をとっ
それで皆さんに買ってもらって対価をいただいてしかもありがとうって言って
いただけるなんてね
もちろん大きな企業に勤めて安定供給するとかということも重要だと思います
ですけどそればかりじゃないでしょ
私今48歳ですあとね20年間ぐらい現役出ようと思っています
なのでもう一つぐらい玉ねぎできるじゃないですか
なので今からねちょっと皆さんからもヒントを頂いて次の今までにないような野菜
玉ねぎよし今度行こうかなと思っています
なによりもこのスマイルボールだってさらさらレートだってこれ育種ですから遺伝する
んですよ
ということはみなさんわかりますよね世界中の玉ねぎにかけて世界中のタマネギは雨
玉ねぎにすることだってできるんです
もちろん9割は辛い玉ねぎがいいかもしれないだけどスーパーに必ず
甘い音スマイルボールみたいなのがあってもいいじゃないですか
世界中にさらさらレッドみたいな健康玉ねぎが並んだら
と思うとちょっとワクワクするじゃないですか
でも気付いたと思いますけれどスマイルボールとさらさらレットをかけて全然辛くない
けれど
健康にいっていうのも理論的にはできるんです
なので
今後は間世界中に今の研究成果を広めていって皆さんからありがとうって言って
いただけるようなことそして新たなチャレンジ
それからもう一つだけ
私この仕事に就こうと思ったのはやっぱりまだまだ食べれない国
人々がたくさんいるこれまでも
人口がまだまで増えていくのに食料が足りてない
もし私の亭主改良の技術がそういう食料を供給するようなことに応用できるならばね
お金の事ばっかりではなくて将来のために皆からありがたいありがとうって言って
頂けるためにそういう仕事ができたらなと思っています
今日は種の話をさせていただきました羽ってやっぱりすべてのスタートで重要だと思う
んです
でも私の付加価値ってたではどれだけですね
農家の方と連携して栽培
そして流通やね系やの仕方とか書こうとかみんなで付加価値をつけてそれで弾貼った人
のところにお金が戻ってくれるような
ねそういうビジネスモデルしないいくら良いため作ったって都会のあるいはビュー2
業者さんを設けさせてあげてるようじゃ何もない
長いですよね
今日はちょっとタネも仕掛けもあるような
誰の話をさせていただきましたご静聴ありがとうございます
[拍手]